[Music]
i uh have something creepy to tell you
and i'm just gonna i'm just gonna come
out this is a safe environment for me so
i think i can share uh you had the uh
you i was excited when when dallas was
coming back because when i was a
teenager it was the biggest show on
television huge
massive biggest thing anybody ever seen
and so i used to like check out dallas
and then i find out it's coming back so
we were doing shows in chicago uh when
when your show came back when your show
premiered it's not the kids with the
karaoke it was awesome oh yeah we had we
had a real blast doing the shows but one
of the nights i get back and it was the
same night that my wife showed up uh and
we're in the hotel room together and
we're lying there on the bed and i'm
flipping channels and i see that dallas
has come back the show that you're in
you guys have brought it back and i'm
excited so i start watching it and i'm
just lying on the bed and i'm not
thinking you know watching the show and
then there's a scene where you enter
and you're in your underwear and you
look absolutely incredible and i'm on
the bed and my wife's in the room and i
said hello
i was like excuse me and i completely
forgot the situation
i had been on my own for a couple of
days so i'm just sitting there my wife i
love my wife the mother of my children
and i'm there and i'm just like hello
and i i so i apologize but uh good lord
that is very flattering thank you
so i'm sorry i just had to i wanted to
confess that to you right up front and i
really enjoyed the show i really did the
show was fantastic this was actually my
first day of shooting your first day of
shooting was the one where you're in
your underwear in my underwear will
there be more episodes like that
i have a perv
i'm sorry but any moment you feel unsafe
you can move to the couch uh
i've got these two guys to protect me
right is that now how weird is that is
that i mean you're a professional
actress is that is that at all
uncomfortable or no i think on a tv show
because you get to know everyone so well
you want to get that stuff over with
because otherwise everyone's like your
brother you know or your sister and then
to make out with your brother later on
does that make sense like you just you
get to know them so well that you're
like oh now we have to make out that's
weird so i'd rather just make out with
them on the first day
so maybe that makes me weird it helps
you get to know people better well let's
get to know each other you're a stranger
it's going to be easier to kiss you as a
stranger than it is once we get to know
each other down the down the line right
so the underwear and all that it's just
a way of sort of breaking the ice it
really was it was like hey guys nice to
meet you i'm now going to get in my
underwear okay
sounds good uh
you you are married your husband is your
husband mind i mean there there's uh sex
scenes obviously in dallas there's a lot
of you know you with these very
good-looking
men uh shooting these scenes does your
husband mind that kind of thing he says
he doesn't but i i asked him recently
because we were watching an episode
together and i was like honey what are
you like watching and he was like he
watches like the edge of the tv so that
it's like it's all a blur to him he said
it's like going through traffic and it's
all just like like it's like peripheral
vision to him he doesn't want to see the
specifics that's so strange that he
decides to i mean the other choice would
be just not to watch it but your husband
decides to watch the edge of the
television
which is so strange it's like his coping
technique it's like i have to tell him
honey it's coming up
um like
look away if you know but i want his
take on on the episode i want to know
what he thinks right would also be
really creepy if he was too into it also
that would be really creepy if he was
like yeah
you know just like settle down pal that
would be yeah that would be really weird
there's a billboard that's everywhere of
you guys all in the shower together
[Laughter]
and first of all i love that larry
hegman jr is wearing his cowboy hat in
the shower
[Laughter]
i don't know what i mean it's kind of
sexy but also it's it's it's also kind
of incredibly strange and weird would
you what happened like when they told
you we're going to shoot a a billboard
of all of you in towels in a shower
uh like how is that how is that cool
like all of us in the shower i don't get
it it's not even erotic like you're not
even standing in an erotic way some of
you are and some of you look like you're
in a police lineup i mean
and look at josh is like we all make fun
of josh because he has like eight abs
it's insane like what he's got going i
even mine i've never had a body that
looked anything like that
i didn't even know what those muscular
groups were down there
uh but anyway so
the day i saw the the photo shoot it was
it was like a water work set so i was
like okay this is gonna work out and
then they hit you with a fan and you get
all into it and you're like okay maybe
this isn't so bad then you get really
into it then you'd start taking off it
now i'm saying
just keep going with that uh